[موسيقى]
اقليم افيرون جنوب غرب فرنسا ذو مساحه
9000 كيلومتر مربع واحد من اكبر الاقاليم
الفرنسيه ارض الهضاب الجيري والوديان
الضيقه لكنه قبل هذا وذاك موطن الروكفور
هذا الجبن ذو العروق الزرقاء الذي يعتبر
من بين اقدم واشهر الاجبان في العالم ولد
في هذه
المنطقه هؤلاء الاصدقاء قرروا ركوب
دراجاتهم والانطلاق في رحله اقتفاء اثار
ملك الاجبان في
العالم الجو ليس حرا في هذا اليوم اننا
نستمتع وسط هذه المناظر الطبيعيه الرائعه
ونتنفس هواء اغون النقي في سع
حتى الان قطعوا 60 ك المرحله الاولى من
الرحله يتوقفون فيها عند مزرعه
الي صباح الخير صباح
الخير ارحب بكم في مزرعه ايكس العائليه
التي تربي النعاش وتستخدم حليبها في صناعه
جبن الروك
فوريس 75 سنه قضت جزءا كبيرا من حياتها
رفقه
حيواناتها
التي ولدت في شهر
يناير هل ترون كم هي محبوبه
وجميله وتعض
كذلك كل اسبوع تستقبل الي سياحا كلهم شغف
لاكتشاف هذه العوالم انها
لطيفه انا احب استقبال السياح وتعريفهم
بحرفنا من ياتي الينا يود اكتشاف المزيد
من المعلومات فنقدم لهم بكل سعاده
هل ترون انها تحاول اكل شعري تحب المداعبه
يتم حلب هذه النعاج من سلاله لاكون مرتين
في اليوم
تقدموا كم عدد النعاج التي يتم حلبها الان
من خلال هذا النظام بامكاننا حلب 40 نعجه
في وقت واحد يمر الحليب عبر هذه المضخه
لينتقل الى خزان الحليب بشكل الي اليس
تتابع عمليه الحلب بدقه وتحاول في الاثناء
الاجا عن جميع اسئله هؤلاء السياح احيانا
يتعجبون ويقولون لي ان هذا المكان مثل
المختبرات اقول لهم هل تتخيلون كذلك ان
تجدوننا بالقبعه والقبقاب لقد عرفت مهنتنا
تطورا ملحوظا الى اللقاء اليس الى
اللقاء لكن ماذا عن تذوق جبن هذه النعاش
اين الروكفور اذا في الشمال الغربي قد
يجدون ضلتهم هناك في الافق عند سفع هذه
المرتفعات وبالضبط في قريه روك فور هنا
استقر صانع الجبن الاسطوري منذ عده قرون
في هذا القبو الذي يوجد في المستوى الثالث
تحت الارض والذي يعود الى الف سنه ترقد 6
الاف قطعه من جبن الروكفور يصهر عليها
صانعها الماهر الذي يعرف اسرارها جيدا حتى
القديمه
منها تقول اسطوره الروكفور ان راعيا ابصر
راعيه اغنام فراح يجري ورائها ونسي جبنه
وقطعه من الخبز داخل الكهف عندما رجع وجد
خبزه متعفنا وجبنه مغطا كذلك بطبقه عفن
زرقاء سواء كانت الاسطوره صحيحه ام لا فان
حبيبات الفطر هي التي صنعت شهره الجبن
بنسيليوم روك فورتي نوع من الفطر يمنح
للجبن هذا اللون
الازرق سنلاحظ الان تطور البنسليوم داخل
الجبن واذا كان موجودا في كل
مكان وجدته
كذلك نعم الرائحه ايضا يجب متابعتها
رائحه حليب
النعاج للحفاظ على رطوبه وطراوه الاجبان
تقدم الطبيعه يد المساعده هذا الجرف الضخم
المطل على القريه يعمل كمكيف هواء طبيعي
تربطه شبكه واسعه من الانفاق تحت الارض
بالقب عبر هذه الصدوع يدخل الهواء الى
الجرف وعندما يلامس الصخور يتشبع بالرطوبه
والبروده فيصل الهواء الى القبو رطبا
وباردا نلتقي الان بالاصدقاء الذين يذهبون
الى زياره قبو اخر يصنع فيه الروكفور انتم
هنا اذا وسط جبرييل كولي اقدم قبو في
المنطقه قفوا هنا من
فضلكم بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من صنعه لابد من
ابطاء عمليه النضج من خلال تغليف الجبن
باوراق
القسير لمع دخ ال نقوم
بتغطيته هيا لنقم جميعا
بالعمليه لا تخط كثيرا كلكم
مخطئون كلنا مخطئون نعم يتميز ورق القصدير
بمرونتها الشديده لذلك لا نضغط عليه بشده
نحاول تغليف الجبن بهدوء لنكسب بعض
المليمترات من الورق نحكم اغلاقها وفق هذه
الطريقه هل نتذوق هذا الروكفور ام لا
تذوقنا ثلاثه انواع من جبن روكفور مختلفه
تماما عن بعضها البعض في الذوبه والنكهات
الاصدقاء الشباب يتعرفون على اوجه اخرى
تتميز بها منطقتهم التي تحتوي على العديد
من الخصائص تماما مثل جبن الروك فور ذ
المذاقات والنكهات
المتعدده